[Music]
well the green your deal is not the only
piece of legislation the Democratic
Party is now pushing in its efforts to
take over the United States economy and
your personal life Democrats also
proning a bill to take over health care
it's called the Medicare for all bill
has over a hundred co-sponsors in the
house that's a lot if you want
perspective the bill among other things
would ban private health insurance so to
paraphrase President Obama if you like
your plan you definitely will not be
able to keep your plan the projected
price tag for this well no one really
knows here's one estimate 32 trillion
dollars over the next decade but cost is
no object as they often tell us Chris on
is a radio host of former staffers
Senator Chuck Schumer and he joins us
tonight Chris there's so many questions
here thank you by the way for coming on
I know that you support single hair lots
of people do lots of polls show that
Americans want guaranteed health care so
it's not even a question of whether
that's popular it is the question is how
to get to it and I and I wonder how can
you sell a bill that makes it illegal
for most people to pay doctors out of
their own pocket if they want to that's
kind of a little fascist is it not you
know I don't think there's any bills out
there that have any serious chances of
passing that would not allow people with
their own money to do whatever they want
with it with their don't how about this
bill that has 60 co-sponsors it's not
some fringe thing by Cynthia McKinney or
whatever this is like a real thing over
a hundred Democrats and it would not
allow private contracts between citizens
and physicians like what yeah I don't I
don't believe that that would actually
be the final bill that would ever pass
but I do support Medicare for all and I
think that the American people would
like to see all Americans covered and
whatever the Democrats proposed
Republicans are gonna call it socialism
just like they did with Obama anti
slogan I don't want to throw slogans
around I want to assess through it the
meat of the legislation pending in the
House of Representatives tonight again
that has
the overwhelming support from your party
so that legislation as noted two times
previously would ban private contracts
between citizens and physicians it would
also pay for abortion now you're gonna
tell me most Americans support roe v
wade do most Americans support using
federal dollars to pay for abortion up
to birth I don't think they do not even
close no and so why include again like
like I've said before you know there
used to be a time in America where we
had a legislative process where people
would propose things and people who had
different ideas or proposed other things
we would meet in the middle
now people propose things and then
people just say that socialism that's
about abortion sad bad that's evil just
I'm not I'm not saying you are I'm not
saying you are but the conversation we
you had in your first segment is very
similar to what happens when people
propose legislation in America today
okay becomes a good versus evil batter
instead of discussing the merits of the
policy I'm tracking the Americans this
is the most flammable straw man ever
constructed I'm trying to do what you
lament isn't done any longer which is
assess the actual details of an actual
piece of legislation that would force
taxpayers to pay for abortion up to
birth nobody there's no large group of
Americans that wants that why you'd have
to be a freaking lunatic ideologue to
put that in a piece of legislation why
are they doing that you would also have
to you would also have to repeal the
Hyde Amendment and do some other things
before that would you our laws in the
country because if you're pro-choice and
you're writing the bill you would add
things that support your position and
people who are anti choice would then
try to amend that bill to get to a
compromise to bring 300 members instead
of 230 members supporting a bill which
is all we've passed bills on in the
House of Representatives last couple
used to be in America that you would get
Republicans and Democrats supporting a
bill people who are of like
knowledgeable proper ability wants to
solve problems in America maybe we
should write bills that aren't riddled
with total fringe positions that only
crazy people support I mean ladies
anybody should say you know what or
maybe people on the other side would say
take that out of the bill and I'll
support it and then we'll have a good
conversation about how we bring health
care to all Americans their love it's
already bellick district we could spend
less money on health care in this
country
like they look we spent 16 percent but
this is not the average other company
does country does not dive time for the
talking points I just anyone who writes
a piece of garbage this is done it's not
interested in solving the problem I
think we can both agree on that
Chris on thank you very much no good to
see you thank you